So we have this equation
right over here.
12 to the negative 2
power, times 1 over 72
to the fifth power, is equal
to 2 to the a power times 3
to the b power.
And what I want you to do
now is pause this video
and find values of a and b that
satisfy this equation, where
a and b are two integers.
And I encourage you to use
all of the exponent properties
that we have now learned
in order to tackle this.
So I'm assuming you've
given a go at it,
so now we can work
through this together.
So what I'm going to try to do,
is get these numbers, like 12,
and these numbers
like 72, I want
to express them as products
of powers of 2 and powers of 3
So 12, for example, is
equivalent to 3 times 4.
So I could write
this as 3 times 4.
And all of that is going to be
raised to the negative 2 power.
Now, why am I
interested in 3 times 4?
Well, 3 is clearly a power of 3,
and 4 is clearly a power of 2.
This is 2 squared,
we're actually
going to write it as
2 squared in a second.
So this is 3 times 4 to
the negative 2 power.
And then 1 over 72
could be rewritten
as-- so it's going to be
times-- 1 over 8 times 9,
72 is 8 times 9.
8 is a power of 2,
9 is a power of 3
And, of course, we're going to
raise that, to the fifth power.
And that's going to be equal to
2 to the a, times 3 to the b.
I'm just going to keep trying
to simplify the left hand,
in terms of powers
of 2 and 3, and then
see if we can match what a and
b need to actually be equal to.
So let's look at
this right over here.
So this, if we have the
product of two numbers raised
to an exponent, we know
from our exponent properties
that this is going to be
each of those numbers, raised
to the exponent,
the product of that.
Or the product of each of those
numbers raised to the exponent.
So it's going to be 3
to the negative 2 times
4 to the negative 2 power.
And now this right
over here, before,
let me just rewrite
it like this,
this is going to be
the same thing, times 1
over 8 times 1 over 9.
And we're going to raise
that to the fifth power.
Now 3 to the negative 2,
we could just keep as 3
to the negative 2.
That seems like a nice
form to leave it in.
So let me write that as 3
to the negative 2 power.
Now what is 4 to the
negative 2 power?
Well, 4 is the same
thing as 2 squared.
So it's going to be times
2 squared to the negative 2
power.
Now what is 1 over 8?
What is 1/8?
You could view this as 8
to the negative 1 power.
Or you could view
this as 1 over 2
to the third power, which
is the same thing as 2
to the negative 3 power.
And these are consistent,
because remember,
8 is the same thing
as 2 to the third.
So this is 2 to the
third to the negative 1
power, which is 2 to the
3 times negative 1, which
is 2 to the negative 3 power.
So 1/8 is 2 to the
negative third power.
And by that same logic,
1/9 is equal to 9
to the negative 1 power.
Or you could view it as 1 over
3 squared, which is equal to 3
to the negative 2.
And these, once again,
are consistent because 9
is 3 squared, and you're raising
it to the negative 1 power.
So, once again, that's 3
to the 2 times negative 1,
3 to the negative 2 power.
So this is going to be equal
to-- we're raising everything
to the fifth power.
So 1/8, we just established,
is the same thing.
1/8 we just-- having trouble
changing colors-- established
is 2 to the negative 3 power.
And 1/9-- I'm running
out of colors--
is 3 to the negative 2 power.
So let's keep simplifying this.
We have our 3 to the
negative 2 power.
Now this part
right over here-- I
could introduce purple
again-- that part,
that's 2 to the
second power, and then
that raised to the
negative 2 power.
Well, we've already seen, that's
the same thing as taking 2
to the product of
these two exponents.
2 times negative 2
is negative 4 power.
And then, we're going
to take each of these,
we've already seen, taking
the product of two numbers
and raising it to
an exponent, that's
the same thing as
taking each of those,
raising it to the exponent,
or taking the product of each
of those, raised
to the exponent.
So it's going to be
times 2 to the negative 3
raised to the fifth power.
Times, we're in the
home stretch, times 3
to the negative 2 raised
to the fifth power.
So once again, this is going to
be 3 to the negative 2 times 2
to the negative 4, I
think you see the end now.
And now what is this?
2 to the negative 3
to the fifth, and then
that raised to the
fifth, well, we
multiply these two exponents.
That's going to be 2 to
the negative 15, times 2
to the negative 15 power, and
then what is this going to be?
Negative 2 times
5 is negative 10.
So this is going to be 3
to the negative 10th power.
And so, what's this
going to be equal to?
Well if we multiply this one--
let me introduce a new color--
if we multiply 3 to the negative
2, times 3 to the negative 10,
we have the same base, we
would add the exponents.
So that's going to be 3 to the
negative 2 plus negative 10,
which is the
negative 12th power.
And then we have a 2
to the negative 4 times
2 to the negative 15.
That's going to be 2 to
the negative 19th power.
And we want that to be
equal to 2 to the a.
Now, we go to the beginning,
moving back to our equation,
we want that to be equal to
2 to the a times 3 to the b.
Well, we have 2 to the
negative 19th power,
so let's let a equal
to negative 19.
And we have 3 to
the negative 12,
so let's set b is
equal to negative 12.
And we are done.
So all we did, this was just
an aggressive application
of pretty much all of
the exponent properties
that we actually know,
and it's actually
kind of a satisfying problem.